odell beckham as usual his sideline
demeanor
um was spotlighted
and noticeable uh and he addressed it
now gary do we have the sound
of that by any chance or do i need okay
let's roll that i want y'all to hear
what
odell said yesterday roll it talk about
i mean
how how badly you want to win and you
could see it on the sidelines there
uh in the fourth quarter how much this
means to you how passionate you are
uh i know sometimes it gets misconstrued
but uh when when you're over there and
you know that they're showing you on on
tv
what what's going on in your mind and
soul in that in that moment
um i'm pissed and at this point i really
don't care to keep trying to
make make myself look like a good guy
into the world and all that
because i am who i am i got pulled out
of the game the coach said this is the
best decision you know we're gonna
it's eight minutes left and for me i'd
rather take my ass open like a man i'd
rather take my win the same way
um i want to be out there until the last
whistle competing um and as you know
dallas game in the first quarter i got
tackled stubbed my toe
uh into the ground kind of had this
lingering turf toe issue so if i'm not
going to play i'm not going to stand
there with cleats on the sideline and my
toe be jammed in there
but at the same time i never want to
come out of the game win lose i don't
care for up 50.
down 50 i don't ever want to come out of
the game and that's always going to be
my mentality
i'm kind of over you know trying to play
the right thing because
you know i love them to death but
there's people who have plenty of rings
and consider the goat and
they do things on the sideline and other
people do things on the sideline and
they get away
with it and it's classified as passion
because
they're they may have um something
behind
their legacy or whatever it is and to me
well we love this [ __ ] that much it
means that much
there's no way around it i don't care if
i have zero rings 12 rings 20 rings
i love this game of football and i'm
never going to keep
i'm not going to keep building myself to
for the world to feel like i'm mature or
whatever word you would like to throw
around and i'm always going to be me
um and tired of losing um tired of
losing the good teams
and just ultimately want to win and one
day when it's all said and done it'll
we'll all clearly see that but in the
midst in the meantime while we're in it
i'm sure we won't
that's a mic drop that's a mic drop for
me like i've always even when he was uh
you know assaulting the uh the kicking
net
in new york a lot of people made a big
deal out of that i have always defended
his passion because honestly i relate to
it
honestly i relate to it and you know
he i love how he not only called out the
double standard
you know the the tom brady's and he had
to say his name but the tom brady's of
the world
can go off on the sideline and it's
celebrated because tom brady's teams
have been successful he's the
quarterback against any other
but also i love that he's at a point in
his life
where he's over trying to make people
feel good about it or trying to fit in
or conform to what people think about
how he displays his passion i absolutely
love he's like i'm over it like
y'all definition of maturity or whatever
that means whatever y'all whatever y'all
think i need
to be i'm not trying to be that i'm this
is me this is who i am
i'm passionate i'm sick of losing this
organization should be sick of losing a
good team
so yeah i got pissed off and i slammed
my helmet and what let's do better let's
be better
quick quit focusing on my reaction and
focus on the root of my reaction let's
be better
okay all right yeah it's new orleans by
the way
504. new orleans what's up what's up new
orleans
there it is stand up louisiana where
now where uh is he from he's from new
orleans
yes is he from the east
i don't think so i don't think all right
look mike uh
he said a lot of good stuff there he
said a lot of really good stuff
i'm feeling i'm feeling his passion i
love what he had to say about
being up 50 down 50 i don't want to come
out of the game
i want to take the i'll take the victory
i want to take the loss too
coastal was the best decision i'm pissed
about it
love it i love that i love it i can feel
the passion he has for the game of
football
but this is what he doesn't get
he's not a double standard it's not the
double standard that he's talking about
he's like well you know why can this guy
do it
and and and i can't you already
said it odell how many times i've been
to the playoffs how many times
have his team's been to the playoffs
once
i believe that he said if he had stayed
in the number one media market in the
country
and they had won if odell beckham
jr had been on the 2011 giants the team
that won the super bowl
if he had been on that team and he acted
the same way
the new york myth makers would say
that's my guy
look at him he's a winner he's got
passion
he plays the right way he never wants to
come out of the game
the fact is he said it i'm tired of
losing and when you're a loser
you're not looked at the same way i'm
not saying he's a loser but when you're
in a losing organization in a losing
culture
people view you and your team
differently he's right yeah tom brady
does flip out on the sideline but tom
brady has six rings is that fair
i don't know but that's what happens
when you win no that that's no doubt
but the answer is no that answers no is
that fair
you shouldn't only be able to display
passion with the permission
of championships you said these teams
don't go to the playoffs
is that his fault that's not over is
that his phone
let's not overstate that he's just
displaying passion
is that what he's doing that's the
communism
what do you call it petulance you want
another p word he's
most most guys out there are displaying
passion because
you know it's pro football you got to be
out there they're just playing passion
he is he's he'll extra with his right
hand he has emotional yeah emo he
displays
more passion than the next guy most of
the time and that's his prerogative and
that's been
when you when you're when you write but
when you're winning
that is viewed differently and because
that says more about
us that says more about us this is more
about the critics
than it does about the legitimacy of his
reaction
it says more about the people writing
the narratives
it says more about the people writing
the narratives that because
somebody's team like we're assigning
some kind of correlation
between tom brady yelling and screaming
on the sideline and his teammates
with the fact that the patriots won six
super bowls by this rationale
by this rationale if your teams win
therefore that style of leadership flies
if your team's at a different position
mind you at a much more dependent
position
not more dependent but in a different
position mind you if your
teams don't win then therefore
be quiet be like so so you're saying if
the giants have been better if even
that's extreme that's extreme you're
right that's extreme you're not saying
that you're not saying that
but if eli manning hadn't been a shell
of
whatever he was back in 2011 and the
giants would have been better
and they'd have gone to the playoffs
more that would have been received
better that's bogus to me
that's bogus to me and my and again my
problem is
people get threatened especially
from young brash black men they get
threatened by their passion by their
intensity
but when somebody else does it somebody
else does it
oh they're just committed they're just
fiery and odell beckham
i don't think it has i don't think it
has anything to do with with odell
beckham jr being there lots of
uh brash confident uh emotional
black men in the national football
league i don't think that's it
i think it happened michael michael it
happens in the workplace it happens in
the workplace i'm not sure i don't i
don't know
okay i don't believe i don't know why
it's an incident that's different i'm
not i'm not trying to inject race way it
doesn't belong
i'm saying subconsciously it is written
differently
that's true that's true you're
absolutely right thank you for catching
me on that it's always
whether whether it's at the top or the
bottom is somewhere you know it's
at least beneath the surface or maybe
it's over it's somewhere involved
so you're feeling me then you're feeling
me subconsciously
it is received differently when black
men
show passion than it is when white men
show passion
and i'm not saying that this is a matter
of black and white when it comes to tom
brady and odell beckham
specifically that's what i was talking
about but specifically yeah i know brady
has this cash shane because he's the
goat
but because beckham is not the goat he
can't be pissed
he can't be upset on the sideline it is
a double-sided okay
but again i don't better think that i'm
glad he's not gonna be a victim of this
double standard anymore you're gonna say
look i'm gonna be me
take it or leave it yeah but but see but
but odell that's why and you said he's
over it no he's not over it if you're
over it you're not talking you're not
you don't keep bringing it he was asking
no no he didn't bring it up he was okay
you answered okay right
okay there's some stuff i'm if you want
to be real
there's some stuff that i'm over that if
you ask me about it
i'm not i i appreciate your ques you
know the the the blow off answer
i appreciate the question i understand
why you asked the question
but i'm not gonna answer it if i'm
really over it no he's not over it's
something that's on his mind
and i know he put out a video a couple
of years ago we all know he's talking
about you saw the video
he put it out and he spliced it and he
had tom brady
going crazy on the sideline and then he
had him
and he's like well why is it perceived
different it is because of winning
winning
it's what this thing is all about this
is a result business
and you would get it odell beckham jr
you'd get the benefit of the doubt if
your team's won
now it's not your fault that your team
maybe maybe even michael
maybe he would be michael irvin yes he
may be like a lurger and michael larger
brash passionate black winner three-time
champion
okay nobody's but we know but we know
how much circumstances but we know how
much circumstances matter
we know how much circumstances matter
and all i'm saying
time for him to be identified and called
a diva
a lot of these receivers especially they
get called divas
they're called divas and it's just it
just feels
unfair it's always felt unfair i feel
like i've been on the right side of this
issue and i think odell beckham is a
prime example
yeah like goes too far like i don't see
this
when you when you put it side by side
then maybe he goes
maybe it's a little extra for him
it's a little extra so i'm thinking
about players like who are other
passionate players
in football like who who who can you
think of like who has
who would you consider like a really
emotional
excitable player of color in the nfl
you know like who who comes to mind i
know i don't know why i'm drawing
yeah i mean no because there are others
but for a lot of reasons whether it's
new york whether it's his style
whether for a lot of reasons i think
it's fair to say he is among the most
scrutinized and i'm not trying to keep
up for odell i'm not trying to
how about someone like that how about
cam okay
cam cam and you know what we'll talk
about narratives how much differently do
people talk about cam now that he's in
new england
we talked about this earlier oh cam's so
different cam the same duty wasn't
carolina
he's the same dude he wasn't carolina
they just talk about him differently
because of his surroundings
his surroundings he doesn't he doesn't
want anything more
his surroundings it because new england
has legitimized him somehow
but he's not doing anything differently
than he did in new england
speaking in the world i agree speaker
it's his surroundings it's all
surrounding
speaking in new england he's with the
cleveland he's with the he's with he was
with
and i'll let it go but i just want to
point out he's with yeah he hasn't had
in his if he's been in the league uh
odell for six seven years whatever it is
he's been on one playoff team and that
changes everything it's unfortunate but
that's the way
i just think i think it shouldn't but we
talked about new england
it's been a long time we talked we do
family reunions on this show we defend
reunions
it has been a long time since
me you and shalise manza young
were uh in the press conference
trying to get something out of bill
belichick
[Laughter]
now she's a big time yahoo sports
columnist uh shalise it is so good to
see you
um i want to get to your family and just
how you doing in a minute but let's
start with the conversation we were just
having
i think you might have overheard it feel
free to weigh in on on odell beckham and
what he had to say and
juxtapose himself with tom brady you
know this isn't
something that um odell has said in the
past and
and i don't think he's wrong you know it
it's true
that as you guys said black players in
particular and especially receivers
they're always painted as divas and
black players
when they're passionate then it comes
across or or that's portrayed
as you know they're being petulant i
think that's where you use mike and that
they're being brats and you know odell
is a weird guy
um talented is all get out obviously
um but he's a weird guy he hasn't really
won anything yet not entirely his fault
um and people are going to portray him
the way that they
portray him because he's outspoken and
he's not going to back down
and he's not tom brady you know we've
seen people make excuses for tom brady
and
dismiss the you know demonstrative way
that he interacts with his teammates at
times and why is it okay for him to be
that way
but not for other players and i think
it's a perfectly fair question to ask
what what do you think of of beckham's
future though
because i i see i see this changing
i think he didn't have to change who he
is i see it changing by going to a
winning situation
i see what you guys are saying but
winning players
winning black players who are excitable
are described
as just that excitable players who are
winners i think part of his problem is
that he's been with two
organizations that are really struggling
to get into the postseason
michael mike started talking about our
commonality with the three of us
let's take it back to corey dillon what
did everybody say about corey dylan when
he was with the bengals
that he was a jerk that he was a brat
that he was a punk
he was outspoken we all remember those
last year or so that he was with the
bengals and throwing i think
they go to the organization they start
to experience winning and all of that
calms down and for some guys
the desire to win and the need to win
just manifests itself
in ways that not everybody agrees with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports